ça brassait pas mal à l'assemblée
nationale et fin de session oblige parc
voici les moments forts des derniers
mois et ça commence en septembre avec le
chef du parti québécois le parti
québécois est digne de confiance
[Applaudissements]
on a une belle exigence est ce qu on
sait ce qu'on peut maintenant dans la
vie ce qui compte quand on reçoit une
taloche c'est pas la téloche
c'est comment on salive
parce que moi aussi j'apprends ce que je
fais dans les journaux et les oreilles
si on souligne les 150 ans du parti
libéral va soulignons les avec les
poings de beauté et les verrues c'est
pas en coulant série d'un journaux d
information dans les montants des
paiements certains côtés c'est vraiment
gonflé à l'hélium
j'ai été victime d'un coup monté
on a assisté à une déclaration
historique à l'assemblée nationale
on accuse du coup on s'expose et on a
aussi vu un ministre
mal à l'aise avec la déclaration le
soleil
le dauphin le montrer qu'il protège le
parti non ceux déjà vendus au sol
question du pack devient
dysfonctionnelle du scac présentement
n'a jamais été aussi affaiblie
maintenant donner aux familles ce qui ne
s'achète pas
du temps on va mettre plus d'argent dans
un portefeuille des parents qui veulent
un deuxième ou un troisième enfant
pour prendre un transport en commun il
faut avoir le visage et tout le long du
trajet tout le long du trajet mes propos
ont pu être appelée à être interprété je
fais mon homme honorable et je m'en
excuse tout simplement la cession va
reprendre en février préparez vous à de
l'action au retour d'une foule de
promesses
les parties vont vraiment être en mode
électoral en vue du scrutin d'octobre